[Music]
good evening I'm Alexandra rose on the
executive director here at Long now this
is the first one of the talks that we've
done here at the interval that's being
livestream so everyone say hi to the
livestream all right yeah so hopefully
we'll do more of these in the future but
we have many members out there listening
to the livestream the next talk in this
series is is actually with the designer
of this space one of the co designers
Jeffery McGrew
and he's going to be talking about kind
of the future of architecture and the
way we build things with machines now
and he and his wife Gillian started
because we can after they bought a
computer-controlled
routing machine which actually made a
lot of the fixtures that are in this
space and they realized that
fundamentally you can now do things that
only large entities could do before and
so he's been working with autodesk
directly with the CTO at autodesk and
pier 9 on the kind of all the futures of
the way we make things and so he's going
to be giving a talk about that next in
this series and i also want to remind
you that we are selling Stuart's book
where this image this space layers
diagram first appeared it's here and
they're all signed I believe they're all
signed yes they all got signed yes
awesome great ok so that is that's most
of what I have to talk about the I know
that I don't need to give too much of an
introduction to two of our founders Paul
and Stuart but I'll just do it by
telling a little bit of a story which is
that I I got this job back in 1997 quite
a while ago I had hair and I had I just
met several of the board members and was
just starting to work on the clock
project with Danny Hillis and and Stuart
brain called me up and he said Brian you
know and I have been talking about this
diagram and it's about the layers of
human time and so he just started
describing it to me and I started
scribbling something out in an
illustrator and and I kept sending them
back and forth to him in email and and
then you know that it was all fine
except for the very top one where I
started with a kind of squiggly line
stick no more squiggly and then I sent
it back no more squiggly no more
squiggly and so finally I got it
crazy squiggly enough and I thought it
was just something that was just going
to stay just you know kind of a
discussion item and and it has now gone
forward into the world to do all kinds
of interesting things and and I think
back on it now I would have used much
more
care but I think part of it is is kind
of the charm of how it was made and and
now being redrawn with the chalkboard
robot technology so with that I'm gonna
introduce a Stuart brand and Paul Sappho
two of our founders
thank you very much so the order of the
evening is is this Stuart and I see this
is a continuation of a conversation he
and I have been having I'm among the
many people who have been using Stuart
space layer model in teaching at
Stanford and elsewhere and it's such a
powerful tool and we start talking about
we said gee you know it would be really
nice to talk about the origins and and
and also start a conversation here with
how to use the pace layer tool more
broadly in the like so one little detail
you have this is a homework assignment
on the sheet there are a couple of
questions we see this as an opener for
the discussion that you can have in the
bar afterwards though we'll end the
evening with Stuart answering the
questions on this sheet just to get
everybody going what we're gonna do
Stuart's gonna talk first and talk about
the origins of the idea and how he
developed it so it's a wonderful case
study and how very powerful ideas come
to pass and I'm gonna offer a couple of
remarks about how I I'm serve a parasite
living off at his Big Ideas a happy
parasite corrupting youth and a couple
of the surprises I've found in the
process of using a and then we're gonna
go into a group discussion here so
you're teaching this at Stanford is that
right I use it in my class at Stanford
what kind of classes that I teach
forecasting so my course this quarter is
for foresight for innovators me2 97 and
we also use it at singularity University
we have some folks in the room who will
come to later who actually are using it
in their work and teaching amazing how
sound can you hear me okay
really really
little louder is there a louder there's
a gain control somewhere other than me
it's me afraid of that
alright like all good things this was
stolen and it came out of a book I was
working on in the late 80s early 90s
called our buildings learned and the
problem the problem that the book was
trying to address is why do architects
keep making advanced expense buildings
that people absolutely detest and I had
some various angles on that but I needed
something to stitch the whole book
together and then when I was in London
in 1990 I met Frank Duffy and his
partner John Worthington who back in
1972 had done the analysis of how money
actually gets spent in buildings and
typically over a 50 year time frame most
of the money spent on the building will
not be the original construction that's
only one-third two-thirds is spent on
all the remodeling reconstruction and
adding stuff to the skin all these kinds
of things go on later and they figured
out that's where the money is so they've
started a company called GE GW Duffy was
a D where the intent was W and they made
a minute four years of doing basically
remodeling and Duffy was one of the
founders of what's called a facilitation
management and back in 72 they came up
with the fundamental problem of
buildings which is that they're always
trying to tear themselves apart in the
sense that what they called Michelle
which is the outer structure is there
that's the building but then the
services gets swapped out every 15 20
years or so and and what they call the
scenery the space plan especially in
commercial buildings is changing every
five years or so and then what they call
the the sets which is the furniture is
moving on a monthly basis all that
movement tends to tear a building apart
and architects want to design the
perfect building that will stay the way
they designed it forever and nobody can
[ __ ] with so they will put the services
deep inside the walls of the structure
so the only way you can change the
services when you have to do that in 12
to 15 years time is tear down the
building and the architects are fine
with that but the users are not so
anyway I took this scheme which gave me
what I needed which was a sense of peace
layering in buildings and I added a
couple layers to kind of general purpose
this stuff is you know the stuff and the
furniture and space playing the D that
changes like they said it did
I added skin the outside of buildings
tends to change quite a lot sometimes
for technical reasons often for
aesthetic reasons the structure is the
building 60 or 70 years after I finished
the book in this diagram and I started
spending more time with all this
material because I was out talking about
it I realized that I've missed a couple
of things which is that windows are not
part of skin the windows are changing
much more frequently kind of at the
about the rate of services and I
completely left out landscape
architecture which I'm describing here
as scenery which changes it about the
same rate as skin so the way the
building looks in the way the area
around the building looks changes pretty
rapidly in case you think that the
slowest part of this site is not really
eternal take a look at what happened in
Boston between 1860 and 1981 it's just
one building the Old South meeting house
because they're a bunch of fires in
Boston there's only one building that
was there over that whole period of time
but if you look at the streets which is
a sight legal site the political site
the way the streets go and the way the
property lines go the Lots go don't
change and they're not going to change
Boston is going to look like that
forever these huge skyscrapers have to
dance to that quarry
so that's the kind of thing you see with
pace layering and buildings and it's
interesting if you look through the many
Amazon reviews of the book quite a lot
of people decided there was actually
about software and systems and systems
design and I'm pretty sure that they're
you know ends up with saying oh the book
brand if they have something to say
about buildings to about a third of the
reviews or of this sort what they're
responding to is the pace layering
obviously and so as I got a sense of
that and was then moving into this book
the clock belong now in the nineteen
eighty eight ninety ninety nine I got
there thinking this was going to be
about what we do here trying to
encourage long term thinking and
responsibility and is there a pace
layering of civilization that could be
imagined probably not a shearing layers
because civilization society is not
trying to tear itself apart but I've
already learned from the buildings that
how buildings learn over time is that
these fast parts gradually suggest
things to billing which gets integrated
into the slow parts and that's how
buildings become wise over time and
eventually become low despite the
architects best efforts so how is it
going to do that and I was in the studio
Brian Eno in London in 1996 in December
and we got chatting about this and kind
of going through the layers and he
persuaded me that art was not a layer
because art was both operating a sort of
fashion scale but also something that
kind of a cultural scale but fashion
which Brian is extremely interested in
very much as I quality fashion is about
fashion that's why the curly lion it's
always referring to itself and going
back on itself repeating itself and
going deeper into itself and trying all
sorts of changes on itself government we
realized was not the
word laws or anything in economics and
then wound up with govern Nance is it's
the word that probably would work so
that became the diagram and that's
pretty much the way it was drawn by
Alexander a couple of things to say
about it is there has to be slippage
there has to even be a kind of a
negative feedback edginess between the
layers so if Commerce persuades
governance to operate at its pace you
will have maximum cutting down all of
the redwood trees in Northern California
because they get more money from that
than they would from the bank interest
if you have a religious group who thinks
that the governance should not change
from medieval Sharia law you're probably
going to have some serious serious
disjunctions
if you have governance changing quickly
when the u.s. went into Iraq and
throughout the entire bast government
and then had no government as a result
that was like stupidity on the level of
understanding how these cases work the
same thing happened in Russia with the
nature of their revolution the same
thing happened in France with the nature
of their revolution sudden changes in
slow moving layers is probably a mistake
now if you're young or you live in
cities the rule looks more like this
everything's moving you're focusing on
the quick stuff young people are
obsessed with fashion I can tell you as
a 76 year old that old people are
insanely bored with fashion we've seen
it all come by so many times we don't
even want to keep track anymore but on
the other hand half of the world now
lives in cities in a couple decades time
eighty percent of the world will live in
cities so more and more of the world
will be looking at thinking about the
pace layering of their civilization
these kind of
terms now if you're an older person or
you live out the countryside or you work
it long now it looks more like culture
is the big event and fashion is just
something happening often the kind of
trivial distance it is the case is this
century moves on that people are lasting
longer there's going to be more old
people jesse ossible was saying last
week we are now at peak children we will
not have a greater proportion of
children probably for the rest of
humanity and so more and more old people
I mean you know when you get the
together for holidays there's going to
be four generations soon five
generations not as many cousins
how are those generations going to talk
to each other and about what that's one
of the things we'll be learning at me so
sum up the fast layers learn and
innovate and try things slow parts
remember proposing disposing shocks
happen to systems and it's one of the
things you want fast layers in a really
resilient system to be able to absorb it
run with it okay a whole new technology
fine we'll make money out of it and then
the commerce figure Salva to do it and
then that trickles down the government
which integrates the shocks
discontinuity is the big event in the
fast parts continuity is the main event
in the slow parts innovation sometimes
revolution comes from the fast part not
only constancy but constraint if the
slow parts aren't occasionally
frustrating they're not doing their job
but if you don't respect them for doing
that you don't understand all the little
works and by the way you know the fast
stuff we read the newspapers or
magazines things online fast stuff gets
all the attention but guess what the
wallet constraints and so on all the
powers and the slow parts
Aldi's this diagram is having a life of
its own is Jeff Veen here tonight he was
gonna come I didn't even know what a
full stack is but full stack engineers
apparently worked with the whole array
of front-end back-end data store and so
on I didn't know that so this diagram is
having a life of its own out there
there's there's other versions of it
they're getting more and more gaudy I
kind of like that the bottom one is sort
of the earth and here we are doing yet
another version you're cool let's give
him a hand
so the notion of standing in front of
the Pope discourse you know on the finer
points that theology comes to mind and
and I I second
Stuart's notion by all means steel but
if you do steel the way you pay back as
you do your best to try and extend it a
little bit and so I'm not sure I can
extend it much but I can share some
thoughts that have come up in the course
of conversations with my students and
you know there's an old saying the
difference between a consultant and a
professor consultant takes a year's
worth of work and compresses it into an
hour and a professor does the opposite
I'm going to try to be more like a
consultant and I'm going to really come
down to two ideas and a question and the
one slide here so my that's a dark slide
that's that's a real slide two points
first one is the question of speed and
where where does speed interact with
non-linearity and then the second point
I'll come to in a few minutes is the
notion of productive turbulence so the
pace Larry Stewart said you know shallow
is is fast discontinuities discontinuous
slow is more continuous and the like
well and a good example of something
slow would be this the San Andreas Fault
which by the way is relevant to us here
a marvelous example of a slow process on
average it moves about two and a half
inches a year about as fast as your
fingernails grow
it's what determined it and the
processes as part of determine the shape
of the bay area without the fault we
would not have the bay area and it
probably you can pull a thread thread
straight through to the fastest thing in
the Bay Area and that's change in
Silicon Valley if the fault wasn't here
we wouldn't have Silicon Valley and
that's all good news I mean the only
downside is that two and a half inches a
year of course that means in ten million
years
you know recall we're on the east side
of the fault
Los Angeles is on the west side that
means in about ten million years we'll
be a suburb of LA which is not a pretty
prospect so slow stately Magisterial
building the mountains except there are
times when you have nonlinear processes
like the Napa quake this is a picture of
so sometimes deep layers can be also
very fast in discontinuous ways and so I
think of the the difference is it's it's
almost the difference between the
standard and the inverted order with the
pace layer standard order is continuity
is at the bottom discontinuities at the
top slows at the bottom fastest at the
top except there are times when lower
layers move faster than upper layers and
when that suddenly happens that's when
you have revolutions and dramatic
changes the 1906 quake was a moment when
the fault move very quickly had a big
impact of an infrastructure and then you
start seeing effects ripple out through
the other layers
a year later it led to the panic of 1907
because all those insurers who were way
long on insurance in San Francisco had
to pay out and it caused a financial
crisis in London and we had the panic
and there are lots of other examples of
low-and-slow causing high and fast
the explosion of Krakatoa in 1886 was
the final straw that led to the Banton
revolt in Indonesia which is the birth
of Muslim fundamentalism so if you want
to understand Isis today you go back to
the Krakatoa explosion and then the
Lisbon earthquake 1755 changed the
course of the Enlightenment launched
Immanuel Kant's career and give us
Pangloss and Candide the best of all
possible worlds so you see it hitting
culture and just zigzagging all through
once you get one of these big big
changes but what's really interesting is
it also affects a local revolution so
this is of course an s-curve standing in
place for your preferred exponential
change Moore's law and the like
and what's interesting about is it shows
the ordinary or order you know in
Silicon Valley entrepreneurs like to
draw hockey-stick curves but we all know
there s curves for a reason
and the reason why there s curves is
eventually a slower layer catches up
with the fast layer so you know the the
web revolution is leveling off because
now Congress is catching up and trying
to to fix things so it you know the
lower layers can sometimes drag down
things and the only reason Moore's law
in my opinion has installed is it
because members of Congress are so
technologically illiterate they don't
understand it well enough to to mess
with it but also think about tougher
your Square in the Arab Spring tougher
your square in a way happened because a
lower layer culture went ramming up into
governance and we have the Arab Spring
but then governance figured out how to
squeeze the life of the child in its
crib and we went back to the the
Pharaohs in the light so that's a first
idea that slow is slow but it also can
be nonlinear and very often it tends to
be exponential keep in mind the Richter
scale itself is an exponential scale
earthquakes follow a power law and
that's why big earthquakes are rather
rare and just an aside by the way you
know remember you are in a seventy year
old building it was built by the
low-cost bidder for the US government
when it was in a rush the San Andreas
Fault is approximately seven and a half
miles to the west so you know just keep
that in mind if it starts to shake
follow me out that door I'll run
screaming with my hands in the air
so the second point is turbulence what
Stewart was calling slippage hidden in
this non-linearity I think is an even
more important phenomena that the bat
the boundaries between the late pace
layers don't always just have slippage
they also have turbulence and and I've
come to the conclusion that the
boundaries that the pace layers are
actually more interesting in terms of
innovation and change then the pace
layers are themselves
it's the
struck t'v turbulence between pay
Slayers that leads to uncertainty and
surprise and innovation you can think of
those boundaries as the most productive
zones of the space layer pace layer in
effect they are the intertidal zones you
know that's where all the action is in
the oceans right where it touches the
shoreline and and a good analogy so this
is Jupiter and right up there right in
the southern equatorial belt is is a
zone of what's called velocity shear
this is the well spare the physics for
everyone but trust me that the two zones
are moving at different speeds and you
get these little whips and whirls and
that turbulent interaction is the most
interesting part of Jupiter but the
turbulent interaction between pace
layers here in the valley is is also the
same thing think about how the internet
came about this combination of
interaction between culture the
counterculture of the 60s plus
technology there's a reason why the
internet and Stuart wrote was one of the
first people to write about why the
internet was architected the way it was
wasn't an accident it was the
intersection of Technology and and
culture I also have I paw 'this is that
the layers don't just difference differ
in speed they different viscosity that
the lower layers are viscous San Andreas
Fault moves in in nonlinear ways because
it's it's very viscous and and can't
move move smoothly also turbulent
boundaries are really productive zones
for Silicon Valley specifically um you
are here this is the great spot on
Jupiter and it's a very particular kind
it's basically a standing vortex it's
been there for a long time well think
about Silicon Valley as a standing
vortex of different pace layers coming
together and mixing and you know the big
blob up there well that was HP and
there's Apple and little blobs there's
Facebook all coming out and it's
mathematically described it's the von
Karman vortex street so we all live on
von Karman
so I think that thinking about the fact
that turbulence is a really powerful
thing in the pace layers it's not always
bad it's what creates the intersections
of different technologies it throws
people together the like and it adds
lots of lots of surprise so I'll close
with a question thinking about just how
much can you you think about with the
pace layer and it's nice to think about
the pace layer that you know it's really
non-controversial it's really clear
clean architectural will ask yourself
where does dad hang out and of course
this group I suspect we would all put
God right up here and culture yeah it's
like you know yeah you know it's that
thing people do on Sundays and you know
some kind of casual Buddhists and alike
but there are people who might disagree
in fact they might disagree so firmly
that I have to redraw the pace layer
diagram to fit them in so here's my
abstracted out larger pace layer that
they're that take all of human activity
that's an throws below it is bios below
that is lithos the domain of the San
Andreas Fault so you think a BIOS that
thin little you know surface of
atmosphere and stuff at the top that we
we now know it goes into lithos and then
beneath that of course is cosmos and a
very devout religious person would
probably say it's not God's not in
culture he's not even cosmos he's like
behind the whole ball of wax
so as you play with this think about you
know the kinds of where do things fit
what are the sub layers within the pace
layer and you know is there space for
everyone including God and I'll stop
so we have your class here what are you
gonna do yes well the first thing is
that there's no homework about the
homework assignment is over alcohol at
the end but just as a conversation
starter there are a couple of people in
this room there they're more than a
couple of people in this room who have
been using the pace layer stuff
professionally and and I picked on two
of them in advance and I asked that they
would just briefly make a comment so do
we have the hip no we have the hand
he'll he's it on oh you got if you can
go to Andreas so very first so aundrea
just bring them yes
so Andrea is over and she's been doing a
lot of work in forecasting over at
Hayward Cal State Hayward and also
teaching futures methods to high school
students and so just say a word about
how you use pace layers yeah I mean
basically I've been using the pace
layers with students who are between
like 14 and 15 and maybe early 20s 20 21
and I mean basically what it does is
make something that's very abstract
it gives it a framework they have
related to all of those layers in some
way and so it's a concrete a
concretization of the future I mean they
can understand time horizon at you know
a hundred year time horizon five hundred
a thousand in a way that's concrete that
they couldn't have without it and also I
think what what the you know its pace
layer so the sense of that dynamic at
each layer all of a sudden the future
becomes something that they're connected
to and it's just a very useful way for
them as they're really learning how to
deal with abstract thinking to to kind
of have a framework and to connect
themselves really to the long-term
future so we have a lot of fun with it
good thanks Andrea and we can run the
mic over to Pete lighting from reinvent
or
well like a lot of good ideas it's not
just that you apply it literally it's
how did it really affect my thinking and
I was actually around gee being around
the time this came out and it's really
fun influenced my thinking a lot and one
of the things I including the creation
of a company of my last company that I'm
in right now if last three years now one
of the reasons I've thought about this a
lot is to me I think this was always
kind of a ideal or it was kind of like a
way to think about normalcy and I keep
thinking about the early 21st century to
what extent infrastructure is changing
in a kind of an accelerated rate
particularly rather digitization of
everything how culture or kind of
globalizing everything is like
accelerating kind of cultural change at
some level and with climate change how
nature is in fact going through some big
changes that is forcing change now to me
what's interesting is the governance
piece right now is the most static and
in most stasis and most people would
actually in the West and I think
actually around the world would see
there's very little innovation in
governance to respond to those big
changes happening the digitization of
everything the globalization of
everything and ultimately you know
everything going sustainable to me over
time and so to me it's influenced my own
kind of thinking and my company is to
focus on driving more innovation into
governance because to me that's the lag
that's the pace right now or the layer
that is most essentially intro theater
or in basically in need of some
fundamental reinvention and so my
company inventors essentially is helping
drive a lot more innovation into
governance and governance systems and
it's been inspired a lot by thinking
about where is most needed where is the
change most needed today and to my mind
it's in that layer because if we can
flip some real fundamental innovation in
that space the rest of these kind of
transitions could take off much more
fluidly anyhow thank you so it's
concrete and practical the kind of
influence its had on me yeah Pete I
would say that the thing to look for is
where is governance actually being
responsive and it's in cities which
tend to go faster anyway and and city
governments the governance is you know
kind of at the level of potholes there's
not as much ideologies involved and kind
of solving the problems as they emerge a
lot of them are economic and so on and
but national governance I think has some
of the issues you talk about and it's
much more at the kind of ideological
cultural level and what and wouldn't be
surprised that city governance is more
fast-moving and responsive than national
governance and we may well see and are
already seeing economically that that
cities are economically much more
powerful than whole nations in many
cases and we may see a period in which
city states the singapore's of the world
like Venice back when are the really
operative governance elements which
might not be a bad thing so the stick on
governance we had a question and I will
go to the audience in a moment here
question from Miss Arg in the live
stream how will you show X space
exploration in the next 50 years in pace
layers and I think about that in terms
of governance that you know this is a
time arguably where there's waning
national power can city states go into
space is it up to commercial which pace
layers come together to get us into
space and 50 years well you've seen a
migration from it was something that
only governments could do and some
governments are still there China India
and Japan and became sort of meant for
structural with the satellites that
communication satellites but
increasingly it's commercial money
that's SpaceX and so on that's pushing
no and so in a sense spaces is moving
into the more rapid area at least a
closed space the farther out space
further on space is well I mean you on
musk really wants to go to Mars he's not
kidding and I'm really loving the idea I
mean I could nominate all
sorts of people for a one-way trip to
Mars you know it's also interesting
thinking about governance in the origins
of Silicon Valley that it was
intersection of Technology and
governance that launched the valley
because of the geopolitics of the space
race you know an early adopter is
someone who pays too much for something
that doesn't quite work and thanks to
the space race the federal government
were the dream early adopters for the
Intel's mmm-hmm and I think we hadn't
had the space race you know we might
still have analog computers well yeah we
had the Great Salt talk for Mariana
matsukawa basically is saying that the
most radical innovation is comes from
good governance taking chances that
Commerce would never take that aren't an
infrastructural yet you're trying them
out and I guess one of the things that a
really solid institution can be way more
radical and universities that they're
best have this quality and government
R&B at its best has this quality they
don't have to prove stuff at a
commercial pace which is you know just a
couple years time and and then you're
out of the game yeah you know it's funny
it just reminded me a recommendation of
a book you all should look up if you're
across Elliott Jakes by name only by
name he wrote a book and as I know this
is it this is a deal killer with the
scintillating title a general theory of
bureaucracy but it's a page-turner and
he it really is and he has a model of
what he calls time span of discretion
that a manager can be ranked on a one to
seven scale on their time span of
discretion that amount of time from
which they can formulate a goal and the
goal can be achieved so a level one is
someone who thinks 20 minutes in the
future that be your average member of
Congress to a level six or seven a
Gandhi or Matsushita or a Christ who
could set into motion a goal that would
be successfully completed centuries
after they passed away and almost no
that is you know is is the problem with
democracy is it for
the short rewards the short and punishes
the law famous problem and where you see
that in city governments is cities that
go from being crap to being wonderful
typically have mayors that are not
termed out that are in place for 20 30
40 50 years when you get one would love
to have term limits be sort of
optionally Mike Bloomberg made that
happen
to where when you've got somebody you
actually you like and they have these
long term goals and they're good at it
and they're building a team that can
actually make it happen you should be
able to I think do you say actually
we're going to keep this one for a while
and we'll revisit it at each election
period but let them stay in for now
that's a good idea
questions from the audience so who has a
really great question
shitty wanna lose okay let's go to the
gentlemen
dark hair beard right and our goal is to
make Xander move as much as possible and
stand up when you say who you are a
thank you hello well who are you Peter
Marquitos I keep thinking about where
technology falls into this and it seems
to hop around and in my mind but it's
one rather than a layer it's like
gravity okay I don't know if that's a
really great question but I wanted to
ask good why also that that opens up
I've you know I've looked hard at that
when we were doing this because I
thought well you know technology
acceleration Moore's law that's kind of
stuff Scott Athenee or somewhere it
turned out taking it out actually helped
think about technology as how it plays
in these various levels and also
thinking about institutions as you know
you can draw kind of a circle about
where an institution lives and how does
it cross cut across the layers you know
and is there a public side to the
institution that is you know very deep
or a private side that's very deep and a
public side this fast-moving speaking
widget if you had to pick an institution
that sort of Grox pace layer thinking
the best what's your favorite
institution
this gets more question from the
audience I think dr. Zander has a
question I'm holding the mics the
hostage the I've often wondered where
kind of you mentioned it a little bit
with Congress only having a 20 minute
horizon and I find what's interesting
and your example of long-term mayor's
that my favorite one is one of the
longest are mayor's in modern history
was in Japan and he had been in office
for like 40 years and he went against
everybody in all of the local
governments and his own town to build a
70-foot tsunami barrier in the valley in
front of their their town because he
remembered the previous one and it had
never been in use he died in office and
then a few years later came the big
Japanese tsunami they closed the thing
it saved the entire town and and there's
no other mayor that could ever have done
that without that long-term you know
power that he had gained and you know
monarchies also have this kind of
ability to think very long term
democracies we're finding are more and
more and more short-term where does
where do we get our long terminus in
democracies does it have a place do we
have to fix it in another way I keep I
keep coming back to Venice which danced
on the razor's edge for a thousand years
as a mercantile empire and they didn't
have a democracy they had the world's
strangest Republic where there were so
many layers of weird voting that went on
before the people in charge and they
really did turn people out and the Doge
was a total figurehead that was not in
charge of much of anything unless he
inspired people to do stuff like attack
Constantinople or ally with the Moors in
Egypt to knock the Portuguese out of the
Indian Ocean which went over really big
with the Pope
oh that's why your Prince Henry the
Navigator went around Africa so this is
the right thing to do like we said it's
been a long conversation you're just
kidding you know by the way when think
about when Venice went off the rails and
CP snow in the news knocked off the
rails by Napoleon Bonaparte who could
not stand another republic beside his
own yeah but there was some other stuff
around there involving the the Kahn and
snipping off the trade routes in the
competition with Genoa but CP snowed has
a wonderful passage in the two cultures
that I like to refer to as the case of
the blind Venetians and I won't do it
justice but he said he was talking about
in England at mid-century said I am
reminded of the Venetian Republic in
their final years is about fifteen
fifteen twenty fifteen 30 he said they
were very successful practical men they
were men that was they were upper house
he said and they they they knew that
events had become to turn against them
and they knew exactly what they needed
to do in order to stay on top of the
trade and power the problem was they had
become accustomed to the old order they
never found the will to break it and
that was how Venice ended up becoming
sinking into the swamp that once
sustained it with its its ocean and he
admits it's a you know a bit of a myth
but I think is a very compelling myth by
the way Venice is doing fine just now
and it's in business so attracting you
and your money yeah it's coming over
there it's too crowded other questions
let's get some gender balance here is
awesome
Xander it's all the way in the back no
no no we got
bear in mind there are people
live-streaming who are god knows where
they are given the pace of global
warming and change would you change the
arrow for nature on your diagram I think
I'll sit I'll say something about that
at the end because I want to answer
Paul's written question do you want to
say something about them no I don't let
you okay duck it if you wish so by the
way the institution that thinks
completely in layered terms is the long
now foundation and about two hundred
years time it should you know have it
pretty well in hand wait and wait till
you try our peoples member dollars
coming that by then that 200 year old
gin that's what that curly cue line is
in fashion after you leave the interval
bar Xander I hate to do it to you where
are you over here there's a young lady
at the bar
speaking about gin so my question is
about wealth as one of the catalysts
maybe for this acceleration of change
and I wonder what thoughts you have
about the role that in capitalistic
society and sort of you talk about
democracy but there's another layer on
top of that which is capitalism how does
that accelerate the change that we're
talking about and reduce the long term
vision it's a wonderful question
growing prosperity worldwide is a huge
event what's going on absolutely
everywhere and we think of Africa as a
basket case that they have a much
greater growth rate than we do or
anybody in Europe than GDP and all the
rest of it
likewise in Asia and South Asia and so
on maybe one way to think about it is is
prosperity is an urban phenomenon to a
large extent is where the a lot of the
economics or the value-added and all
stuff goes on as people are moving out
of the poverty of subsistence farms
they've got a cousin in town they go to
hang out with a cousin cousin gets them
a job in the squatter city they start to
have a regular income which are they
ever had before it pretty soon the rest
of their family comes to town they leave
the subsistence farm behind which turns
back into forest it's speeding things up
in kind of the urban way that I was
showing that you know the the urban look
of this makes fashion and commerce and
and infrastructure huge and the
developing economies really are
developing that used to be a euphemism
but in the last 3040 years it's become
the truth so they are becoming developed
economies and the way we think about the
way things have happened in Europe or in
North America is increasingly the way
things happen all over the world and
that's why we're becoming a city planet
and how the layers play out in the city
planet versus what was previously a
rural planet is what we'll be figuring
out or dealing with and getting
comfortable with in this century so
China China China I was having a
conversation with someone recently whose
name I can't mention B he said you know
the problem in my countries Chinese is
we have a values crisis you said people
are still members of the Communist Party
but it has no meaning to them it's just
a rotting institution and they don't
have anything else to turn to and he
said we're all pursuing wealth but we
have a values crisis so how does one
when you have rapidly rising wealth how
do the other pace layers interact and
just China need a new religion that's a
great question and that that's a nice
bounce on your question is China is a
classic case this is why I think the
wild card in China is that the Dalai
Lama will save China the
the Chinese are all going to become
Buddhists again Kevin Kelly is persuaded
and he's very persuasive they're all
going to become Christians and they'll
get the morality that way which fine
with me yeah here's the question for the
yeah that's an open question you suck
sure don't have any answer Norville gel
isn't here so yeah question from ron
online do pay slayer changes relate
logarithmic lis in terms of speed bear
in mind this is a data free diagram the
building's diagram there's real numbers
this diagram is just total hand wave and
so you know between linear and
logarithmic sure yet the only thing I
would add is it is amazing I continue to
be shocked by as species we are just not
wired to understand Exponential's I mean
I know people who can do the equations
but they cannot grok exponential said to
me if there was one crucial piece of
literacy that everybody needed to learn
is to thoroughly understand
Exponential's you don't have to get a
slide rule but when you teach it how do
you teach it how do you get people to
believe it well they're all the classic
classic examples is King Kremes
chessboard the servant who invents chess
and the Grateful teen says you know put
what would you like he says I would just
like you to put one grain of rice on the
first square and two grains of rice on
the second square that one works pretty
well you know because halfway through
the chessboard you have more rice than
you know is occupied by the volume of
the Himalayas the other one I tend to
use with parents of young children and
it's best told to the kids and say look
okay when you get that conversation with
your parents about your allowance don't
negotiate for twenty or fifty bucks a
week or whatever it goes where I say
look I'm using a very modest child
just give me one penny in the first week
and then double it every week and
Lindsey
On January 26 that somewhere around
August 1st they will be wealthier than
Bill Gates don't fall for it if your
kids do it so I think we have about five
minutes left I would say that there's
great folly in error that can come from
over attention to Exponential's and I
had this as a believer in the population
bomb Thomas Malthus was right that my
old teacher Paul Ehrlich was right that
human population was on a total
asymptotic curve and we were going to
outweigh the earth pretty darn soon and
all you're saying oh that's your s-curve
oh but this is exactly why we need pace
layers all air like had had the pace
layer diagram the Population Bomb
wouldn't have been a best-seller because
it would have been right you would have
gotten the facts right that it's that
cross impact of multiple layers
operating together that blunts
Exponential's in the same way it turns
hockey sticks into a skirts okay anyway
watch out for Exponential's it's it's a
way that people make people afraid of
super intelligence artificial a eyes
that are going to become singular
cingulate Aryan Lee smart and eliminate
us just because they can that's
exponential horse yet amen
and besides when we finally have
machines that pass the Turing test we're
going to really discover is how many of
our friends don't well so we have I
think we should we are right at the end
of time we have less than five minutes
right yes you can five okay do one
question and then go to straight okay
you have been so patient and I don't
want to and her to have to run anymore
so in who are you I'm sorry I'm Noah
Noah tie I
I'm just a guy
so in your original diagram then from
that piece of notebook paper
you hid like written art and then
crossed it out and so I was thinking
about that and I noticed that um art
often operates on the layer of fashion
but always strives to sort of hop over
all the other layers and then hop
straight to culture and and it seems
like other other fields try to do this
as well so for instance consumer
technology often operates it fashion and
maybe commerce but strives to be
infrastructure and sometimes even
culture um that seem like cheating to
you and like what why how do we
differentiate when we see art how why is
some of it why does someone end up in
culture rather than fashion or vice
versa I think one of the things Brian
Eno was very interested in this and and
he's persuaded that art is dogged ly
non-functional in fashion is dogged ly
non-functional so we wear these colors
but it's not actually any reason to do
it other than color we like or different
the colors that we don't like anymore
because blah blah blah and his views
that surprise and innovation are things
that we need to be braced for because
some of them are quite serious like the
earthquakes and the way we get practice
in dealing with surprises is by these
irrelevant artistic things that occur
what lat my kid could draw that why are
you people all taking so seriously and
paying so much money for it now I have
to think about it weird stuff is
supposed to come from art you go to
Burning Man and your mind is supposed to
get blown several times a day and
a good year you do and you come back
cheers up refreshed and exercised I
think is is Brian's view that art keeps
us exercised with radical originality in
a way that doesn't actually hurt anybody
but nevertheless goes deep good art does
that so bring it on and indeed you're
right it does strive to become deep and
permanent and profound and some does and
that's part of the function of the
layers is that it's a sifting device to
sift the stuff that keeps on mattering
to people it was I mean I remember when
hula hoops and jogging came along in the
same summer and the hula hoops they knew
it was not going to last fast that
summer they only made so many hula hoops
and talking who knows but jogging Mille
moved on to become this whole I go to
CrossFit because jogging started in that
summer exercise became a thing that
civilized people do and it went deep and
it's in there now so you keep on trying
lots and lots and lots of stuff is what
the fast layers are about that would be
a perfect place to stop
except I'm dying to hear your answer to
this question global issue challenge
foremost in your mind of which piece
layer they didn't merge which piece
layers impacts most felt based layer
solution likely to emerge
I'll pick climate change which came out
of a funny intersection hood for
commerce in nature commerce over a long
time put up lots of greenhouse gases
nature is saying oh I know how to do
that greenhouse gases I've had those
before I'll just start warming and doing
all these things
pace layers where it's being most felt
government is interestingly confused
about climate change because we do not
have global governance but we do have a
global problem and climate change and
one of the byproducts of climate change
may well be some of the beginnings or
not there's already beginning series
various economic global bodies and so on
there's lots of scientific global bodies
but I think there will start to be
global bodies because of climate change
with a little more level of agreement
and teeth and so on and where the
solution is likely emergently
straightforward infrastructure the next
salt talk I will now promote is David
Keith the climate scientist and his the
talk is titled patient geoengineering
you ask him here how long will it take
to resolve he says we can do climate
geoengineering direct intervention and
climate probably using aerosols in the
stratosphere we can do it gradually we
can do it carefully we can do in our
ways that are easy to reverse and we do
it patiently which means it'll take 200
years but the idea is that that gives us
enough time to get over putting out too
many greenhouse gases and you can
basically phase the system in with the
idea that you're going to phase the
system out so we do not have to be in
charge of the climate for more than 200
years that's mine
perfect thank you so
I want to thank you Stuart for this
conversation and for coming up with the
paste layer model which given us so much
thought and this gives Jordan
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]